herzlich willkommen ja heute geht es um
nichts geringeres als um die zukunft der
menschheit
unser planet nämlich ist krank die
temperatur steigt und die
umweltzerstörung nimmt ihren lauf
mein heutiger gast fordert darum eine
radikale kehrtwende und zwar sofort
greim exten ist ökonom und war bis vor
kurzem generalsekretär des club of rome
der sich seit 50 jahren um die zukunft
der menschheit sorgt herzlich willkommen
am axen ja wenn wir so weitermachen dann
wird die erde bald zwei grad wärmer sein
als vor der industrialisierung und dann
sagen sie haben wir ein echtes problem
inwiefern hängt denn das überleben der
menschheit von zwei grad celsius ab ich
werde auf englisch antworten
wahrscheinlich sind wir noch 15 jahre
von dieser zwei grad grenze entfernt und
dann wird die menge an treibhausgasen in
der erdatmosphäre eine erwärmung um zwei
grad unabwendbar machen eine exakte
zeitangabe ist nicht möglich wegen
verzögerungen im atmosphärischen system
es braucht lange um darauf zu reagieren
aber es sind ungefähr 15 jahren wenn wir
dumm genug sind es so weit kommen zu
lassen wird eine kettenreaktion
ausgelöst
das arktische eis schmilzt schneller und
das schmelzwasser absorbiert mehr
sonnenwärme während eis hitze
reflektiert wird diese vom wasser
absorbiert dadurch wird der prozess
beschleunigt der permafrost in sibirien
und kanada wird rascher schmelzen und
das darunter eingeschlossene co2 und
methan freisetzen
ein großteil der regenwälder wird
absterben wodurch noch mehr co2 in die
atmosphäre gelangen wird durch diese
kettenreaktionen wird die erde um 3 4
und 5 grad wärmer
das wird jahrhunderte dauern aber
unseren planeten in eine zeit zurück
katapultieren in der kaum noch leben
möglich sein soll
deswegen hat man 2015 in paris sich auf
ein ambitioniertes ziel geeinigt nämlich
auf diese 15 grad und gerade letzte
woche ist ein sonderbericht erschien des
weltklimarats derzeit welche folgen das
hätte und wir schauen uns dazu kurz
einen beitrag aus der tagesschau die
konsequenzen der erderwärmung sie sind
bereits sichtbar
extreme wettersituationen mit langen
hitzeperioden und extremer trockenheit
sind nur ein beispiel dafür in ihrem
sonderbericht zeigen die klimaforscher
auf welche szenarien bei einer erwärmung
um 1,5 bzw 2 grad eintreten könnten
fazit ein halbes grad unterschied mache
sehr wohl etwas aus das heißt zum
beispiel konkret dass wir weniger stark
niederschlagsereignisse haben dass wir
weniger überschwemmungen haben
das heißt auch dass in gewissen
bereichen die duschen perioden weniger
häufig und auch weniger intensiv
ausfallen um nur ein beispiel zu nennen
es bedeutet aber auch dass
beispielsweise gewisse ökosysteme die
korallenriffe neben vielleicht teilweise
gerettet werden könnten
die sonst dem untergang geweiht sind
wenn die globale erwärmung bis zwei grad
ansteigt
um das 1,5 grad ziel noch zu erreichen
brauche es aber die notwendigen
anstrengungen
man müsse eine schnelle trendwende
einleiten das heißt wir müssen gezielt
auf eine null emission situation
zusteuern also netto null und der
bericht sagt klar eine obergrenze von
anderthalb grad ist immer noch ein
haltbar wenn wir bis mitte jahrhundert
rund 20 50 auf netto null kommen
der neueste sonderbericht des easy ist
auch grundlage für die nächste
weltklimakonferenz
diese findet im dezember im polnischen
kattowitz statt
hört man bis zur mitte des jahrhunderts
sie sprechen von 15 oder 20 jahren was
ist jetzt richtig
beides steht ich sage genau das gleiche
wenn wir heute beginnen unsere
emissionen jedes jahr in regelmäßigen
quanten zu senken kann das 30 jahre lang
hinhalten wenn wir sie jedes jahr um
drei prozent senken kommen wir bis 2050
auf null nicht klar ist aber was das
wirklich bedeutet
heute hängt das ausmaß der emissionen
davon ab wie viel energie wir
verbrauchen und das wiederum hängt
direkt von der größe der wirtschaft ab
das läuft absolut parallel wenn wir
nächstes jahr die emissionen um drei
prozent senken im folgenden jahr um
weitere drei prozent und nach drei
jahren eine reduktion von fast zehn
prozent erreicht haben muss auch die
wirtschaft um zehn prozent kleiner
werden
außer wir können sie von den emissionen
entkoppeln was bisher nicht möglich war
daher müssen wir unseren lebensstil
radikal ändern wenn wir dieses ziel
erreichen wollen
wir können nicht bis 2049 warten und
dann alles anders machen
wir müssen jetzt beginnen je länger wir
warten desto schlimmer wird es sein
es geht darum das schlimmste zu
verhindern deswegen fordern sie in ihrem
neuen buch auch einen radikalen wechsel
sie sagen die party ist vorbei wir
brauchen eine eine radikale umformung
unseres wirtschaftssystems unserer werte
und da sprechen sie auch für den für den
club of rome der seit 50 jahren
eigentlich sagt und das wachstum
kritisiert 1972 kam ein bericht des club
of rome die grenzen des wachstums
hauptaussage war ein grenzenloses
wachstum ist unter begrenzten ressourcen
nicht möglich um die prognose war das
unser wirtschaftssystem in der mitte des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts
zusammenbrechen wird hatten die rechte
ich sage es ungern aber sie hatten recht
denn es ist eine tragische geschichte
der bericht die grenzen des wachstums
war grundsätzlich korrekt ich muss
klarstellen
die studie war keine prophezeiung
sondern sei
der in mehreren szenarien auf was
geschehen wird falls wir nichts ändern
es heißt darin wenn wir nicht weniger
ressourcen brauchen wenn wir das
wachstum von bevölkerung und wirtschaft
nicht bremsen wird 2030 oder 2040 das
system zusammenbrechen
doch diesen kollaps wird man lange im
voraus sehen und seine folgen werden
lange danach sichtbar bleiben
wie bei jeder größeren veränderung in
der geschichte ereignisse wie die
französische revolution oder der erste
weltkrieg gründeten sich schon jahre
vorher an und man sah die folgen noch
jahre später
so kündigt sich dieser kollaps bereits
heute an die klimaveränderung ist das
offensichtlichste signal dafür das
aussterben von tierarten
migrationsprobleme die verschmutzung der
meere und der atmosphäre
all dies ein zeichen dafür dass wir zu
stark aufs gaspedal drücken im
unterschied zu heute hätten wir 1972 das
problem verhindern können inzwischen
stecken wir mittendrin und können einzig
versuchen die folgen zu minimieren der
kollaps lässt sich nicht mehr verhindern
vorschläge sprechen
zunächst interessiert mich mal was kann
ich denn als privatperson tun dagegen
also es gibt ja jetzt in 50 jahre 1968
damals war das laugen das private ist
politisch eigentlich könnten die
bürgerinnen und bürger und konsumenten
durch einen radikalen verhandlung
herbeiführen indem sie ihr
konsumverhalten einfach ändern wenn ich
vorträge halte fragt man mich immer
wieder was kann ich tun
ich verstehe diese frage denn ich
versuche selbst alles mir mögliche zu
unternehmen um das system zu ändern
leider lautet die antwort fiel kann man
nicht ausrichten
auch wenn man veganer wird und jede
flasche rezykliert wenn man ein
elektroauto kauft und anstatt zufrieden
mit dem zug reist
machen sie das aus ich probiere ich
bemühe mich trotzdem reise ich oft mit
dem flugzeug was meinen co2 fußabdruck
verschlechtert und auch wenn jeder in
europa sich bemüht so nachhaltig wie
möglich zu leben wird dass die zukunft
nicht
denn neben den drei bis vierhundert
millionen europäer leben in der welt
fast siebeneinhalb milliarden menschen
die nicht so handeln und während der
ökologische fußabdruck in der reichen
welt größer ist wächst der dafür in
indien china und afrika viel schneller
auch wenn also milliarden menschen in
der reichen welt möglichst nachhaltig
leben würden änderte das nichts an
unserer zur hälfte sei bei ihnen gab es
so einen persönlichen auch erwähnte sie
haben da vor ihm habe ich gelesen im
bankensektor er gearbeitet auch für die
liberale britische wochenzeitung die
keine ist und dann irgendwann kann diese
wende und sie kamen zum körper führungen
was was hat das ausgelöst das ist eine
sehr gute frage die auf eine
interessante wende in meinem leben
hinweist ich arbeitete in hongkong
schrieb oft über china und verbrachte
viel zeit in südostasien
das war mitte der 2000er jahre also kurz
vor der finanzkrise
weil sich länder wie thailand indonesien
und malaysia bereiste sah ich dass das
wirtschaftswachstum dort den menschen
keinen höheren lebensstandard bescherte
sondern sie in den städten in eine
andere art von armut stürzte sie hatten
zwar anteil an der geldwirtschaft
mussten aber oft hart arbeiten und
lebten unter der zunehmenden
luftverschmutzung
da erkannte ich was wir sagten stimmte
irgendwie nicht dann kam die finanzkrise
wie ich und unser team beim economist
vorhergesagt hatten
und man sah wie schrecklich die folgen
für viele menschen war
da dachte ich in den letzten 20 jahren
haben wir ein auf wirtschaftswachstum
beruhendes system eine philosophie
propagiert die den menschen nicht hilft
sie weder aus der armut holt noch die
bestehende ungleichheit verringert ich
ging zu den herausgebern des economist
und sagte wir müssen über die bücher
gehen und unsere thesen überdenken
doch beim economist teilte man man in
handlungsrahmen
heute sind sie dort auch soweit und
gehen durch diesen prozess was sie
interessant ist aber ich verließ den
economist schrieb ein buch stellte
nachforschungen an und kam zum schluss
dass wir gesagt hatten ist falsch wir
müssen unsere haltung ändern
das wachstum hat grenzen es ist schon
wirklich wir werden gleich noch über
diese radikalen veränderungen sprechen
die es nach ihrer ansicht braucht jetzt
ich frage mich einfach die schweiz hat
die bevölkerung hat den letzten jahren
über die neue energiestrategie 2050
abgestimmt daher weise muss die schweiz
die den ökologischen fußabdruck
verkleinern wir leben so aus bräuchte
oder aus gebe es vier als hätten wir
vier erden zur verfügung
aber wir haben uns darauf geeinigt
ausstieg aus der atomenergie mehr
erneuerbare mehr energieeffizienz und
weniger emission ist das für sie auch
nur kosmetik was da die politik derzeit
entscheidet in kürze los die schweiz
geniesst einen wunderbaren ruf bezüglich
sauberkeit reiner luft und
lebensstandard irgendwie leben hier alle
in eine art blase
was aber in vielen ländern europas der
fall ist doch was sie sagen stimmt
ebenso die schweizer haben einen sehr
großen ökologischen fußabdruck fast den
größten weltweit die meisten leben
tatsächlich als stünden uns vier erden
zur verfügung und sie sind nicht gewählt
ihren lebensstil von sich aus zu ändern
deshalb kann diese veränderung nicht
nach den spielregeln des freien marktes
erfolgen indem wir uns schrittweise
entscheiden ein anderes system
anzuwenden weil es profitabel ist und
ökonomisch sinn macht wir müssen die
menschen durch regulierungen dazu
bringen ihr leben zu ändern
leider ist das notwendig das heißt nicht
dass wir ins finstere mittelalter
zurückkehren müssen sondern eher zu
einem lebensstandard wie in den 1970 er
oder 1960 er jahren
das heißt nur wenige besäßen ein auto es
gebe keine billigflüge und man würde
keine ferien auf den seychellen buchen
wir würden zudem nicht so viel
konsumieren und wegwerfen wie heute wir
können einen guten lebensstandard haben
wir müssen nicht leben wie die
höhlenmenschen aber wir müssen unsere
heutige lebensweise ändern und zwar
radikal aber sie sagen die menschheit
wäre das freiwillige nicht machen man
muss sie zum überleben eigentlich
zwingend weil ich sie richtig verstehe
jetzt ist es so sieht sie entweihen ja
eigentlich den heiligen gral der
ökonomen nämlich dass das wachstum und
sagen das ist sozusagen die wurzel des
übels auch des klimawandels das
wirtschaftswachstum
warum dann können sie das noch mal
erläutern das ist sehr einfach
damit die wirtschaft jedes jahr wächst
müssen wir ganz klar mehr produzieren
wir müssen hier verkaufen und daher mehr
produzieren
dafür müssen wir mehr ressourcen wie
metallische rohstoffe gewinnen oder öl
fördern zur produktion von plastik was
immer wieder herstellen wir müssen jedes
jahr mehr produzieren aber darf ich kurz
sollen folgen wenn ich jetzt eine neue
app für mein iphone produzieren dann ist
das doch ein paar kleine ressourcen für
außer für das iphone software nicht
sicher braucht man für dienstleistungen
weniger ressourcen doch man benötigt
einen computer eine internetverbindung
und das wird auch etwas hergestellt
wenn sie haareschneiden brauchen sie
weniger ressourcen aber es gibt nicht
viele solche berufe
der größte teil unserer wirtschaft
basiert heute immer noch auf dem
verbrauch von ressourcen
das symbol und um diese güter zu
produzieren brauchen wir energie ganz
einfach wir müssen elektrizität oder
eine andere art von energie produzieren
und 80 prozent dieser energie stammen
von fossilen brennstoffen 80 prozent und
auch wenn wir viel in erneuerbare
energien investieren brauchen wir gemäß
der fossilen brennstoff industrie auch
noch in 20 jahren vor allem fossile
brennstoffe
und dieser 80 prozent erzeugen co2
methan und stickoxid was die globale
erwärmung zur folge daher ist dieser
wachstums druck die direkte ursache des
klimawandels
also ich sage das wachstum ist noch
sozusagen die ursache von weiteren übeln
nämlich arbeitslosigkeit was mich sehr
überrascht hat und soziale ungleichheit
absolut richtig wir reden vermutlich
später noch darüber warum wir unser
leben nicht ändern
doch ein grund ist dass welt konzept in
unseren köpfen dass unsere vorstellung
wie die welt funktioniert wie wir uns
entwickeln was fortschritt und glück
bedeuten und das meiste ist falsch was
schwer zu begreifen ist denn es ist ein
unglaublich großes konzept aber die idee
wirtschaftswachstum seien nötig ist
grundlegend falsch
wir lebten jahrhundertelang ohne
wirtschaftswachstum und hatten auch
keinen besonders hohen lebensstandard
doch das ist eine andere frage
wir müssen unterscheiden zwischen
lebensstandard und wachstum
sie müssen wir denken wir haben 200
jahre industrielle entwicklung hinter
uns durch die kluft zwischen der reichen
und der armen welt ist heute größer als
1820 und der graben zwischen armen und
reichen in europa ist heute größer als
1914 also vor dem ersten weltkrieg
bevor das ganze wirtschaftswachstum hat
demnach die ungleichheit die schere
zwischen reich und arm nicht verringert
sondern vergrößert wie thomas pkt in
seinem berühmten buch das kapital im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert vor ein
paar jahren schrieb unser ganzes system
builder und die reichen das geld fließt
nach oben nicht nach unten in die
taschen der armen
doch wir glauben das gegenteil weil man
es uns beigebracht hat das gleiche gilt
für die arbeitslosigkeit in der reichen
welt beobachtet man seit 1990 das rasche
wirtschaftswachstum in die geschichte
und trotzdem hat die arbeitslosigkeit
zugenommen
wir haben mit dem mann gesprochen im
vorfeld dieser sendung der das ganz
anders sieht und zwar mit sagen wir
trotz vom schweizer think tank avenir
zwesten gehören zu uns das kurz an
heute gibt es eine ökonomie eigentlich
einen weitgehenden konsens das
wirtschaftswachstum ab einem gewissen
grad die arbeitslosigkeit reduziert und
nicht umgekehrt
es gibt sogar einen namen für diesen
zusammenhang das ist das sogenannte öko
nische gesetz das ist wahrscheinlich
weniger eingesetzt als einfach ein
stabiler empirischer zusammenhang den
man seit jahren beobachten kann gerade
auch heute sieht man dass er wieder in
europa in den letzten jahren hat das
wachstum etwas zugenommen
und jetzt revidiert auch die
arbeitslosigkeit sie geht zurück
jetzt behauptet gray gestern noch dass
das wirtschaftswachstum die ungleichheit
verschärft oder erhöht wie sehen sie das
über diese frage wird bei den ökonomen
schon hunderten von hunderten von jahren
eigentlich darüber diskutiert wie der
zusammenhang zwischen wachstum und
gleichheit oder eben verteilung ist
somit ich würde sagen das zwanzigste
jahrhundert konnte man das neben auch
empirisch überprüfen
auch da gibt es dann einen ökonomen der
sich einen namen gemacht hat das ist der
herr kunz netz der nach dem modell iq
zuletzt genannt das ist ein zusammenhang
der zeigt wenn das wenn die wirtschaft
wächst am anfang dann nimmt die
ungleichheit zu aber dann kommt so in
einen tipping point und dann nimmt die
ungleichheit wieder ab bei den ländern
ist der zusammenhang nicht so eindeutig
aber auf der globalen ebene auch da
besteht sich ein konsens
wirtschaftswachstum hat der welt
geholfen jahre mode ist zurückgegangen
in den letzten 50 jahren mehr als in den
500 jahren je zuvor und es ist nicht nur
materiell dass es den leuten besser geht
sondern das zeigt sich auch in anderen
indikatoren wie der kindersterblichkeit
wie die leute bei dem älter also die
lebenserwartung steigt die homer toten
nehmen ab und so weiter also dauer ist
wirklich glaube ich ein konsens da dass
wir das wachstum auf der welt insgesamt
global gesehen geholfen
ja die welt wird besser global gesehen
dank des wachstums
die welt geht es besser die wirtschaft
ist gewachsen ja beides ist nicht
unbedingt miteinander verknüpft
es hängt davon ab welche periode man
betrachtet wenn samuel rusch sagt die
arbeitslosigkeit gehe zurück oder die
ungleichheit sei weniger ausgeprägt die
zahlen die ich ihnen vor in nannte
nämlich das 200 jahre
wirtschaftswachstum die kluft zwischen
arm und reich weltweit vertiefte und das
in den letzten 100 jahren die
ungleichheit in der reichen welt
zugenommen hat stammen von der oecd also
aus reichen ländern
es sind offizielle zahlen sicher stimmt
es dass nach dem zweiten weltkrieg bis
in die späten 1970 er jahre ein starkes
wirtschaftswachstum erfolgte und
wohlstand herrschte die
lebensbedingungen verbesserten sich es
gab weniger ungleichheit arbeitsplätze
wurden geschaffen
war das nur wegen des
wirtschaftswachstums ich denke das
wachstum war eher ein nebeneffekt
nach dem krieg begannen wir tief unten
wir mussten alles aufbauen da er das
wachstum und die besseren
lebensbedingungen
doch im wesentlichen unterschied zu
heute nahm zu jener zeit die regierung
großen einfluss es war der beginn des
wohlfahrtsstaates krankenversicherungen
wurden geschaffen arbeitslose
unterstützt sozial renten gezahlt
all das war möglich weil damals der
staat eine viel größere rolle spielt
ende der 1970 er jahre bekamen die
neoliberalen immer mehr macht dann
begann ende der 1980 er jahre das
kommunistische system das ihnen als
einziges die stirn bot zusammenzubrechen
seither erleben wir eine viel stärkere
neoliberale wirtschaft mit einer
rückwärtigen stoßrichtung was die
ungleichheit wieder verschärft jetzt ist
für mich die frage ob man das kind
gleich mit dem bade ausschütten muss
oder ob es folgen des wachstums gibt die
nachhaltig sind grünes wachstum und auch
darüber habe ich noch mal mit mit
sammelgut gesprochen wir haben uns das
kurz an wenn wir von box- und sprechen
dann meinen wir das thema innovationen
technischer fortschritt also es geht ja
nicht darum dass da irgendwelche zahlen
einfach aus dem hut gezaubert werden
sondern
den bestehenden innovationen technische
fortschritt das ist ganz wichtig jetzt
wenn man den klimawandel anschaut finde
ich faszinierend dass zum beispiel wenn
wir den schweiz nehmen dieser prozess
längst auch eingesetzt hat seit den
achtziger jahren sind die emissionen in
der schweiz konstant
das reicht natürlich jetzt nicht um
irgendwelche klimaziele zu erreichen wie
man es in paris gesetzt hat aber
immerhin man sieht dass sich das
emissions- und die missionen vom
wirtschaftswachstum entkoppelt haben zu
einem gewissen teil
und das wäre ohne wirtschaftswachstum
nie möglich gewesen und nochmals es gibt
situationen die dahinter stehen nicht um
das wachstum an sich sondern das was war
es dann eben am schlossberg körper
innovationen technischer fortschritt und
labels sind glaube ich kann man wirklich
sagen dass eben das wirtschaftswachstum
nicht in lebens in der sünder ist
sondern es ist teil dieser lösung dass
man immer einbeziehen muss wenn man das
klima retten will sozusagen
ja was ist dann mit wachstum das durch
grüne nachhaltige technologien und
innovationen erzeugt wird mehrere
interessante fragen zum beispiel ob wir
wachstum überhaupt brauchen ob es
technologische lösungen gibt oder ob
grünes wachstum eine option wäre
if you take nimmt man das
bruttoinlandprodukt der reichen welt und
teilt es durch die zahl der bevölkerung
gibt es bei weitem genug wohlstand
einkommen und arbeit für alle
die wirtschaft muss nicht wachsen
problematisch ist einzig dass der
wohlstand ungleich verteilt ist und es
deshalb arme und reiche menschen gibt
würde man das bruttoinlandprodukt
einfach durch die zahl der bevölkerung
teilen könnte jeder gut leben wachstum
ist also nicht nötig das ist ein märchen
dass andere märchen ist der glaube wir
könnten das problem innerhalb des
existierenden systems lösen
der versuch grünes wachstum nachhaltige
wirtschaft zu fördern ist völliger
unsinn
es ist eine populäre botschaft sie
klingt gut denn die menschen meinen sie
müssen nicht so viel ändern
es genüge das system ein wenig
anzupassen und alles werde gut
doch unser ganzes system hängt vom
wachstum den ressourcen und der
profitmaximierung in jeder phase des
prozesses ab was die ungleichheit erhöht
und das ganze wird vom bedürfnis nach
mehr wachstum angetrieben
auch beim sogenannten grünen wachstum
tut man dasselbe man braucht all diese
energie die emissionen generiert wir
müssen von der idee loskommen dass es
eine lösung innerhalb des bestehenden
markt systems gibt mit dem beheben der
klimaveränderung lässt sich kein profit
machen das ist der profi ins extreme
aber es kommt darauf an wie diese
energie erzeugt wird also welches mit
nachhaltigen lösungen und so weiter
erneuerbaren energien ist wäre wachstum
kein problem
zuerst müssen wir das energieproblem
lösen ja es hängt davon ab wie wir
energie produzieren
doch zuerst einmal dauert es sehr lange
bis wir überall auf solar- wind- oder
nuklearenergie umstellen können auf
energien die keine emissionen erzeugen
und es wird viel geld kosten
inzwischen wird immer noch jedes jahr in
die ölindustrie investiert letztes jahr
kamen 70 gigawatt neue fossile energie
hinzu und davon wurden ganze 40 gigawatt
aus kohle erzeugt die investitionen in
alte energie werden also immer noch
erhöht was das problem verschlimmert
aber auch wenn wir ein komplett
erneuerbaren energiesystem hätten aus
was fertigt man solaranlagen und
windmühlen elektroautos haben batterien
und die sind aus ziemlich üblen metallen
deren rohstoffe begrenzt sind noch
benötigen wir für die herstellung von
hunderten produkten ressourcen und
energie das können wir langfristig nicht
mehr tun wir müssen einen weg finden uns
davon zu lösen
deswegen sagen sie sei es braucht einen
systemwechsel und es braucht verbote
bestrafung oder zumindest besteuerung
auf alles was der umwelt und dem klima
schadet wollen sie konkret dass
fliegen oder das autofahren verbieten
nach und nach ja das klingt schockieren
für leute die über das wochenende für
100 franken nach barcelona oder rom
verreisen wollen und das heute tun
können aber für die umwelt gibt das
keinen sinn sie sagen ich wollte das
system ändern
ja und nein ich wünsche mir ein anderes
wirtschaftssystem
aber jetzt ist nicht der richtige moment
darüber nachzudenken wie ein besseres
nachhaltiges wirtschaftssystem aussieht
dafür braucht es wohl jahrzehnte oder
generationen wir brauchen so etwas wie
eine neue aufklärung
wir müssen unser ganzes soziales system
überdenken der zwischenzeit müssen wir
aufhören die atmosphäre zu verschmutzen
unserem planeten zu schaden
wir müssen also alles stoppen was
schädigend ist nämlich kohle zu
verbrennen und öl und gas zu verbrauchen
und zwar so schnell wie möglich es
bleiben uns vielleicht 20 jahre aber je
rascher wir damit beginnen desto
einfacher wird es obwohl die gefahr groß
ist dass wir trotzdem probleme bekommen
aber das genügt nicht wir dürfen nicht
mehr auto fahren fliegen und mit dem
schiff reisen denn das alles generiert
dieses problem
natürlich finden das alle verrückt es
ist auch verrückt denn je länger wir
zuwarten desto radikalere maßnahmen sind
nötig es ist ähnlich wie wenn der arzt
zu ihnen sagt sie leiden an lungenkrebs
und dürfen nicht mehr rauchen und sie
antworten das geht nicht es ist so
unangenehm doch sie müssen aufhören zu
rauchen
ihr habt es tropft dann ist es halt so
müssen auch wir aufhören und deinen weg
finden das möglich zu machen muss leute
die von der automobilindustrie abhängig
oder in der luftfahrt tätig sind müssen
unterstützt werden damit sie nicht
persönlich unter den maßnahmen leiden
und überhaupt aufhören können
sie machen in ihren büchern ganz
konkrete vorschläge beispiel sagen sie
jeder darf nur noch jährlich 1000
kilometer fliegen zum beispiel mit dem
autofahren sind 3000 kilometer dann
fordern sie einen internationalen
strafgerichtshof
an dem anderen manager oder eigentümer
von firmen attraktiv umweltschädigend
sind das klingt für mich nach einer
ökodiktatur wir haben das sagen und die
frage ist also man das kann man ja
behaupten aber die frage ist wie wir das
umsetzen
ja ich sage nicht dass er einfach ich
weiß wie schwierig das ist
wir stehen mit dem rücken zur wand wir
sind in einer situation die so etwas wie
eine kriegs mentalität erfordert wir
müssen in kürzester zeit eine sehr große
wende in unserer wirtschaft herbeiführen
denn es ist ein notfall pflegenotstand
wir müssen viel verändern obwohl es
schwierig ist nehmen sie den jüngsten
report des weltklimarats aus dem vorhin
zitiert wurde
35 prozent reduktion der emissionen bis
2030 80 prozent bis 2040
das geht nur wenn wir unser verhalten
ändern
ich verstehe wie schwer das ist wenn wir
jetzt damit beginnen können wir die
emissionen jedes jahr um drei prozent
reduzieren
das scheint machbar aber es sind 35
prozent weniger autos 35 prozent weniger
flüge 35 prozent weniger schifffahrten
in zehn jahren das ist eine gewaltige
veränderung
wir haben die wahl
wenn wir weitermachen wie bisher wird
die existenz der gesamten menschheit in
frage gestellt so viel steht auf dem
spiel
es wird nicht sie oder ihre kinder
treffen aber ihre kinder und enkel
erwartet ein ziemlich unangenehmes leben
und zwar in den nächsten jahrzehnten
schauen sie nur im mittelmeergebiet in
20 30 jahren wird es nicht mehr möglich
sein dort zu leben es wird kein wasser
mehr geben man kann kein getreide mehr
anbauen die leute werden aus
griechenland teilen süd- italiens oder
süd portugals wegziehen müssen
es wird nicht nur in bangladesch so sein
sondern uns in europa wird einen das ein
bisschen klar und dann versteht man
vielleicht auch warum sie so radikale
vorschläge machen also der eine ist ja
in diesem buch in ihrem letzten buch ein
prozent ist genug zusammen mit jürgen
brandt als stellvertretender
generaldirektor des wwf
schlagen sie so etwas wie eine ein kind
politik vor für industrieländer also sie
sagen 80.000 dollar verzichts prämie für
frauen mit 50 die kein kind oder bloß
ein kind haben unsere freiheit
ich bedauere dass wir das geschrieben
haben
denn es gab massive gegenreaktionen vor
allem aus der deutschsprachigen welt was
wir damit meinten ist trotzdem wichtig
wie gesagt ist die eine hauptursache des
klimawandels unser wirtschaftssystem die
andere hauptursache ist die zunahme der
bevölkerung als ich 1960 geboren wurde
lebten drei milliarden menschen auf die
erde
heute sind es nahezu acht milliarden
jedes jahr kommen 80 millionen die
einwohnerzahl deutschlands hin zu drei
milliarden menschen sind sehr jung ihr
ökologischer fußabdruck wächst also noch
doch darüber wird nicht diskutiert diese
tatsache wird ständig unter den teppich
gekehrt
wir denken zudem das sei ein problem der
armen welt die chinesen ihn der
afrikaner
sie müssten aufhören kinder zu gebären
was jürgen randers und ich sagen wollen
wir sollten darüber diskutieren und uns
bewusst sein dass wir in der reichen
welt auch teil des problems sind denn
unsere kinder werden einen viel größeren
ökologischen einfluss haben als eine in
afrika geborenes kind aber wenn sie
finden das muss diskutiert werden warum
bereuen sie dann dass sie das
geschrieben haben weil alle über diese
80.000 dollar prämie stolpern und das
lenkt vom probleme ab über
bevölkerungspolitik zu sprechen ist so
heikel weil die leute unglaublich
emotional darauf reagieren weil es um
unsere wohl persönlichste freiheit geht
alle denken sie hätten ein sonderrecht
kinder zu hart und das verstehe ich als
unser buch ein prozent ist genug
publiziert wurde kam auch die große
migrationswelle nach deutschland und die
bewohner deutschlands fragten sich was
heißt es deutscher zu sein was bedeutet
es für uns wenn unsere bevölkerung
abnimmt und die zahl der migranten
steigt wir trafen einen nerv auch
deshalb waren die reaktionen so
emotional
ich bedauere dass sich diese zahl
genannt habe aber ich denke immer noch
dass das bevölkerungswachstum eine der
hauptursachen unserer probleme ist
trotzdem diskutieren wir nicht darüber
die natur wird das problem für uns lösen
wenn wir nicht vorher eine lösung finden
das wünsche in ihrem buch schlagen sie
auch einen einen abend für einen
geordneten übergang vorschreiben sie
also wo wir zu sagen diesen
systemwechsel vornehmen können und darin
gibt es auch ein amt für die medien und
für deren aufsicht wollen sie auch die
pressefreiheit abschaffen bevor
wie ich bereits sagte müssen wir anders
darüber nachdenken nämlich so als ob wir
auf einen drohenden krieg reagieren das
erfordert eine andere mit einem problem
waren wir in den letzten zehn jahren
ständig konfrontiert
ich will es nicht wie donald trump fake
news nennen aber in vielen berichten
heißt es der klimawandel sei nicht
wirklich ein problem sondern werde das
schreiben klima skeptiker es werde
aufgebauscht von den linken die nicht
wirklich verstehen wie die welt
funktioniert
damit haben die medien das problem
verschärft
denn viele leute sind ernsthaft verwirrt
und wissen nicht was wirklich passiert
und was sich ändern muss
die medien haben also in diesem prozess
eine negative rolle gespielt
doch sie müssen dazu beitragen dass die
menschen verstehen wie notwendig diese
veränderung ist wenn in die nachrichten
der werbung und den medien beide seiten
der argumentation präsentiert werden
verwirrt dass die leute und das ist in
dieser situation nicht hilfreich hof
aber ich meine das eine ist zu sagen was
die leitmedien berichten sollten das
andere stimmen zu verbieten natürlich
und da wäre es ist skeptisch ich möchte
mit ihnen noch darüber sprechen wie
teuer die ist es das ganze eigentlich
wird und wer das bezahlen soll weil da
haben sie ja auch ganz konkrete
vorschläge bis zu einem gewissen grad
ist das unwichtig die kosten spielen
wirklich keine rolle denn geld ist nur
eine erfindung es sind nur zahlen und
computer geld existiert nicht wirklich
es ist nur etwas das wir erfunden haben
und dass uns unglaublich umtreibt als
das bankensystem 2008 in die krise
stürzte druckten die zentralbanken der
welt geld und tun es bis heute nicht in
den usa aber in europa und japan drucken
sie ständig geld und versuchen damit die
wirtschaft und den bankensektor in
schwung zu halten billionen von dollar
und franken werden gedruckt wenn geld
gedruckt wird zur rettung des
bankensektors können wir auch geld
drucken um unseren planeten zu retten
geld ist nicht das problem
aber was würde es kosten das
energiesystem über die nächsten 20 jahre
zu ändern kostet vielleicht 10 bis 15
prozent des bruttoinlandprodukts das ist
eine riesenmenge
wenn man es über 15 bis 20 jahre
verteilt ein prozent pro jahr
daher der titel unseres buches 1 prozent
ist genug
wie können beginnen die wirtschaft in
die richtige richtung zu lenken ohne
dafür allzu viel ausgeben zu müssen
nicht mitgerechnet sind aber die
ressourcen die im boden bleiben die
sogenannten verlorenen investitionen
nämlich die nicht geförderten öl kohle
und gas ressourcen die firmen aus diesem
sektor werden finanzielle probleme
bekommen
nicht eingerechnet sind zudem die
kompensationsleistungen für die leute
die in der automobil- und
luftfahrt-industrie ihre arbeit
verlieren
insgesamt sind es 30 40 prozent des
globalen bruttoinlandproduktes plus eine
abnahme des bip
die kosten sind also hoch aber wir
können sie über zehn jahre verteilen
warten wir zehn jahre müssen wir viel
schneller annehmen sie sagen ja auch die
besteuerung spielt einen ganz zentralen
eine rolle also man sollte eben die
richtigen dinge besteuern sagen sie
nicht die arbeit sondern rohstoffe
emissionen müll abfall man solche die
die reichensteuer 100 prozent
erbschaftssteuer und so weiter reduktion
der arbeitszeit fordern sie auch alle
diese diese vorschläge die müssten ja
global durchgesetzt werden weil das
klimaproblem ist kein nationales
problems und ein globales problem da
stellt sich für mich die frage wer setzt
das durch oder wer geht als vorbild
voran da hat mich überrascht zu lesen
dass sie die hoffnung setzen auf china
auf den papst raps militär nicht nur
[Musik]
okay wir haben keine globale regierung
um dies durchzusetzen
ich wiederhole nochmals ich habe nie
gesagt dass er einfach sondern es ist
für mich der einzige gangbare weg und um
ehrlich zu sein
meine hoffnung dass es umgesetzt wird
ist sehr klein ich bin diesbezüglich
nicht sehr optimistisch aber es ist klar
wir haben keine globale regierung und es
ist nicht die rolle der uno das zu
übernehmen
ich arbeite oft mit der uno zusammen die
leute dort fühlen sich so machtlos wie
die meisten von uns
wo sollen wir also beginnen bei denen
die das problem am besten verstehen
aus meiner erfahrung sind das die
bewohner der deutschsprachigen länder
dort sind die leute gut gebildet
besitzen ein umweltbewusstsein und haben
schon oft zum westen hier gemeinschaft
gehandelt das ist also ein guter ort um
zu beginnen in deutschland österreich
teil in der schweiz vielleicht
skandinavien diese länder verstehen das
problem und haben das potenzial anderen
als beispiel zu dienen
warum nennen china shipping hat sich das
spezifische ziel gesetzt aus china eine
ökologische zivilisation zu machen
die chinesen sind die schlimmsten
umweltverschmutzer der welt aber
investieren auch mehr in erneuerbare
energie als die ganze restliche welt
zusammen
absolut letztes jahr haben sie mehr
investiert als die usa in 50 jahren
die chinesen sind zwar große
umweltverschmutzer wollen das aber
ernsthaft ändern
sie sehen die probleme besser als die
meisten anderen und da sie sich nicht um
demokratie kümmern müssen können sie
veränderungen viel einfacher umsetzen
dann haben sie den papst erwähnte papst
franziskus hat sich ausdrücklich zu den
problemen des wirtschaftssystems
geäußert sein erstes rundschreiben
laudators sie das vor ein paar jahren
herauskam war unglaublich präzise
bezüglich des klimawandels zum militär
in deutschland und den usa versteht das
militär die risiken bezüglich sicherheit
und migration in zeiten des klimawandels
sehr gut sich außerdem haben wir
fachleute aus dem justiz und
bildungssystem
es ist eine sehr seltsame koalition von
organisationen und ländern die das
problem tatsächlich verstehen und etwas
dagegen unternehmen wollen wenn wir dich
in heessen die katholische kirche und
teile europas zusammen nehmen kommen wir
auf die zwei bis drei milliarden
menschen die wirklich etwas ändern
wollen
meine idee ist wenn sie ein beispiel
setzen werden ihnen die anderen
vielleicht folgen das ist wohl die beste
chancen die wir momentan haben aber
leider sind geht es im moment hat nicht
voran
ich möchte mit ihnen jetzt darüber
sprechen woran das liegen könnte und
adrian brücke ein verhaltensforscher aus
der uni bern schreibt menschen sind dann
zum handeln bereit wenn sie sich von ein
problem betroffen fühlen und glauben
etwas dagegen tun zu können
und beides ist beim klimawandel eben
nicht oder nur mit
gegeben was tut man jetzt dagegen
er hat absolut recht und das ist eines
der größten probleme
im sommer habe ich in der schweiz die
gratiszeitung 20 minuten gelesen da
wurde über das wunderbare badewetter
geschrieben und die leute realisieren
nicht dass der anstieg um zwei grad
celsius unseren planeten zehn millionen
jahre zurück katapultiert es scheint
eine so kleine veränderung
den meisten ist nicht bewusst dass das
heutige wetter nicht von den emissionen
beeinflusst wird die vor einer woche
freigesetzt wurden sondern auf
emissionen reagiert die vor 15 jahren in
die atmosphäre gelangt was passiert in
den kommenden 15 jahren unabhängig davon
was wir tun es wird bergab gehen und
erst wenn es uns allen völlig klar wird
wenn wir die feuersbrunst in
griechenland mitverfolgen oder indien
hongkong vor ein paar wochen den
schlimmsten sturm seit je wenn wir das
alles sehen und uns die zusammenhänge
klar werden dann ist es zu spät
das heißt es braucht den leidensdruck es
braucht katastrophen dürren
überschwemmungen stürmen damit wir
handeln ansonsten ist das problem
irgendwie diese verzögerung ist zu
langsam die ganzen zeithorizonte sind zu
weit für unseren menschlichen verstand
ich das richtig einer der wichtigsten
gründe warum wir nichts ändern ist
unsere unkenntnis der sogenannten
rückkopplungsschleife in der atmosphäre
etwas was den wissenschaftlern bekannt
ist nämlich dass ich erst heute auswirkt
was wir vor 15 jahren taten wenn sie
einen topf auf den herd setzen um wasser
zu kochen zünden sie das gas an und es
braucht zeit bis die energie für die
erhitzung des wassers wirksam und das
ist ein anderes risiko in diesem fall
aber es gibt eine zeitspanne zwischen
unserem tun und dessen folgen
das verstehen viele nicht und es ist
sehr schwer ihnen das begreiflich zu
machen und sie dazu zu bringen ihr
verhalten zu ändern
daher mein vorschlag die leute
zusammenzubringen welche die tragweite
verstehen
hoffnung gibt mir das täglich mehr
menschen die risiken
kennen der bericht des weltklimarats vor
einigen wochen stieß auf großes echo in
den medien also verstehen mehr menschen
die risiken
wir bewegen uns in die richtige richtung
aber leider immer noch zu langsam dann
gibt es noch die dieses problem der
verantwortung die fusion dass jeder von
uns verantwortlich ist bis zu einem
gewissen grad aber jeder hat das gefühl
dass es ein tropfen auf den heißen stein
und ich möchte nicht mit der veränderung
erfahrung andere sorgen dass das tun
wie löst man diese probleme was sind für
sie die wichtigsten diese idee wir als
konsumenten könnten die welt verändern
ist unsinn
auch die vorstellung wir seien die
ursache des problems ist falsch weder
sie noch ich haben entschieden
kohlekraftwerke zu bauen
deshalb ist es wichtig sie haben es
vorhin angesprochen eine art
internationalen gerichtshof einzusetzen
es gibt leute die dafür verantwortlich
sind leute die entscheidungen getroffen
haben politiker oder die vertreter der
öl kohle und gas industrie die
investitionen tätigten
im wissen dass diese probleme eintreffen
werden die ölindustrie weiß seit mehr
als 20 jahren um den klimawandel und
investiert weiter
meiner meinung nach müssen ihre
vertreter für die probleme zur
verantwortung gezogen werden sie sind
die lösung sie müssen aufhören mit dem
was sie tun was sie und ich unternehmen
wird nichts ändern
wir müssen die ursachen stoppen also
diese industriezweige die frage welche
strategie man wird macht man auf
panikmache wieder klappt fragen schon
seit 50 jahren macht oder versucht man
es mit moderaten geschichten zu machen
mit der erfolgsgeschichten und ich würde
auch interessieren wie das für sie ist
die schreiben an einer stelle die große
herausforderung wird mentaler natur sein
das heißt im kopf wir dürfen den
optimismus den mut nicht verlieren was
machen sie persönlich gegen krieg nicht
diese verzweiflung angesichts dieser
dieser tatsache
das ist eine gute frage an gewissen
tagen wache ich auf und denke es ist zu
spät ich kann nichts tun an anderen
tagen denke ich ich muss weitermachen
es ist ehrlich gesagt sehr schwierig
nicht nur für mich sondern auch für
viele mitglieder des club of rome die
seit langem in diesem bereich arbeiten
sie sind emotional damit verbunden und
wollen das richtige für den planeten und
die menschheit tun als die grenzen des
wachstums heraus kam wurden die autoren
ausgelacht obwohl sie recht hatten
manchmal ist es extrem schwierig
optimistisch zu sein aber um margaret
thatcher zu zitieren es gibt keine
alternative
wobei sie damit er das gegenteil meinte
wie ich wir müssen eine lösung für
dieses problem finden
wir müssen vorwärts machen ich glaube
nicht an die idee wir müssten positive
optimistische geschichten erzählen es
ist eine sehr amerikanische vorstellung
dass wir ein hollywood happy end braucht
wir müssen realistisch sein
das leben wird in den nächsten 20 jahren
schwierig werden unser lebensstandard
wird nicht besser die löhne werden nicht
steigen
wir werden sie schwierige entscheidungen
treffen müssen und das klima wird uns
mehr angst ein jahr ist alles schön zu
färben als wäre unsere zukunft flauschig
rosa ist nicht hilfreich
dann wird man nur enttäuscht zugegeben
den leuten angst einzujagen hilft auch
nicht aber wir müssen realistisch sein
man muss doch die leute irgendwie zum
handeln bringen egal wie würde ich jetzt
sagen wenn die situation so zum
schlimmsten bestellt ist und jemand der
mir hoffnung verbreitet aus angst der
zeit oder seit 23 jahren ist ergo der
ehemalige us-vizepräsident
friedensnobelpreisträger und ich konnte
vor einem jahr mit ihm mit ihm sprechen
er ist sehr zuversichtlich dass wir das
schaffen und zwar aufgrund von
technologien die immer günstiger besser
werden wir schauen uns ganz kurz
einlassen dann ein berühmter ökonomen
der verstorbene rudi dornbusch sagte
einmal bis etwas passiert geht es länger
als man denkt dann aber passiert ist
viel schneller als man es für möglich
gehalten hätte und diese art von
exponentielle veränderung wir kennen das
aus dem bereich der technologie mit dem
burschen gesetz mobiltelefonen und
vielen anderen geräten
es ist sehr spannend dass dieses gleiche
muster jetzt bei erneuerbaren energien
auftaucht bei der led beleuchtung bei
elektrofahrzeugen batterien bei
tausenden neuer technologien
die welt befindet sich gerade im frühen
stadium einer globalen
nachhaltigkeitsrevolution ermöglicht
durch digitale werkzeuge wie die
künstliche intelligenz das internet der
dinge
sie hat den umfang der industriellen
revolution aber mit der geschwindigkeit
der digitalen revolution
sie ist eine realität in unserem leben
und wir sollten sie als basis für echte
hoffnung wahrnehmen
wir können das lösen wir werden es lösen
die entscheidende frage ist wie schnell
wir sie lösen werden und dass wir darauf
vertrauen können den point of no return
nicht zu überschreiten
das ist die stimme der englisch
sprechenden welt
wir ziehen ja auch nicht in den krieg
und fragen wie können wir davon
profitieren
doch genau das tut al gore er fragt wie
können wir daraus gewinn erzielen
wenn ich oder meine kollegen in den usa
einen vortrag halten hört man uns nur zu
wenn wir ein business szenario
präsentieren
das ist die antwort und du kannst davon
profitieren
sonst hört keiner zu das tut allgäuer
technologie kann helfen ja wir können
davon profitieren
ja wir können erneuerbare energien
produzieren aber keiner profitiert davon
wenn man eine stadt umsiedeln oder
höhere flutmauern bauen muss niemand
profitiert vom kampf gegen insekten
plagen oder von der armut die afrika
erfassen wird
es gibt hunderte beispiele die belegen
dass dadurch kein gewinn entsteht
womöglich beträgt der zwei prozent
konzentrieren wir uns also auf die
restlichen 98 was er sagt klingt sehr
schön funktioniert aber nicht
es ist klar sie plädieren dafür dass es
ein umdenken braucht ein anderes meint
nicht nur ein anderes wirtschaftssystem
sondern auch andere grundwerte und sie
sagen an einer stelle die werte der
aufklärung wir müssen neu gedacht werden
wie werde wie fortschritt freiheit
demokratie
können sie das erläutern das wird lange
dauern
als ich jünger war faszinierte mich die
aufklärung ich bin schotte und die
schottische aufklärung war eine sehr
starke kraft
damals wollte ich wach sein und an
diesem prozess teilhaben darüber
nachdenken was eigentum freiheit und
fortschritt bedeutet heute realisiere
ich ich will nicht sagen das ganze habe
eine falsche wende genommen
aber dinge wie das wirtschaftssystem
unsere sicht der natur unsere werte
bezüglich besitzt um und preis denken
vieles davon stammt aus jener zeit dass
die frankfurter schule behauptet mit der
dialektik der aufklärung angesagt genau
das hat uns hierher gebracht und das ist
kein guter ort es führt uns in eine
falsche richtung wir müssen unsere werte
überdenken was bedeutet fortschritt
nicht wirtschaftswachstum nicht die
zunahme des bruttoinlandprodukts sicher
aber die verbesserung der wohlfahrt
es geht darum besser zu leben mehr zu
entdecken eine höhere lebenserwartung
und lebensqualität zu erreichen stelle
ich mir jedenfalls vor es bedeutet
langfristig zu denken und im
gleichgewicht mit der natur zu leben
man darf freiheit nicht gleichsetzen mit
extremen individualismus es geht nicht
um egoismus oder wettbewerb
competition wir brauchen eine
kooperative gesellschaft und müssen
daher viele unserer grundwerte
überprüfen
auch die demokratie es gehört zum
heutigen zeitgeist dass alle fordern wir
brauchen demokratie gegen randers sagt
gern irgendwann in den nächsten 20
jahren fragen sich die leute in europa
warum china in 50 jahren mehr gewachsen
ist und mehr für mehr menschen erreicht
hat als europa obwohl es nicht
demokratisch ist und jemand wird sich
fragen vielleicht ist die demokratie
teil des problems ich entstamme einer
guten demokratischen sozialistischen
familie aus schottland ich glaube an die
stimme des volkes
aber mir ist auch klar wenn wir für eine
lösung des klimaproblems die zustimmung
aller brauchen dauert es zu lange
heute ist das demokratische system und
das sage ich ungern ein hindernis für
diese veränderung denn wir müssen alle
damit einverstanden sei wir brauchen den
konsens in der gesellschaft
und wenn die leute diese thematik nicht
verstehen ist das sehr schwer zu
erreichen
ich schlage keine diktatur vor aber wir
brauchen eine gruppe von leuten so etwas
wie technokraten damit wir die nötige
wende durchsetzen können
im interesse aller
freilich beinhaltet das auch ein hohes
risiko natürlich damit beginnen sich
aber irgendwo müssen wir anfangen
doch das lenkt von der zentralen frage
ab denn wir müssen viele unserer
grundwerte überdenken
das wird wie die aufklärung mehrere
jahrzehnte dauern
deshalb braucht es zwei schritte zuerst
muss die schädigung der natur gestoppt
werden
dann müssen wir schauen wie wir vorwärts
gehen wollen sex ist beginnt der sich
gebracht
wie sollten wir dann nehmen wir das
beispiel der freiheit das jetzt als
individuelle freiheit verstanden wird
mit katastrophalen folgen in der zukunft
für unsere enkel und ich sage mir
freiheit verstehen
damit reagieren wir zurück zu immanuel
kant oder john stuart mill definierten
sie freiheit völlig anders freiheit ist
das recht zu sagen und zu tun was man
will so lange es anderen menschen nicht
schaden
es geht um die freiheit des denkens des
ausdrucks und der verwirklichung von
ideen nicht darum so egoistisch wie
möglich zu sein ohne die folgen für die
gesellschaft zu bedenken
das problem ist dass diese betroffenen
ja irgendwie noch keine stimme haben die
von unseren jetzt in handlung betroffen
sind nämlich diesen in zukunft sowohl
das ist so schwer zu verstehen hat
deswegen wir haben uns in eine situation
gebracht
eine allianz die veränderung verhindert
ist der sogenannte historische block der
zurückgeht auf antonio gramsci
philosophie der 1930 er jahre
wir haben diesen knäuel von ideen wie
wir die welt vorwärts bringen
dank wirtschaftswachstum kleiner
regierung weniger regulierung
individueller freiheit eine loge ist von
dem viele dieser ideen sind grundlegend
falsch und die ursache unseres heutigen
problems diesen ideen knäuel zu
entwirren braucht zeit auszuarbeiten
wodurch wir es ersetzen sollen braucht
auch zeit und ich sage nicht ist er
einfach
haben sie ideen wir haben noch ein
bisschen zeit mit ihnen darüber
diskutieren wie das aussehen wird das
war eine eine lebensform eine
gesellschaftsform die die wirklich
nachhaltig ist und die in einklang oder
in der balance ist mit der natur wissen
ja ich habe einige der grundlegenden
prinzipien in diesem buch aufgelistet
sie sind wohl für die meisten menschen
sehr seltsam es bedeutet keine ständige
zunahme des ressourcenverbrauchs es
bedeutet die drosselung des
bevölkerungswachstums es bedeutet im
gleichgewicht mit der natur zu leben
es bedeutet die wirtschaft nicht den
zahlen des bruttoinlandsprodukts zum
essen vielleicht heißt es kein geld
system zu haben
es erfordert ein radikales umdenken als
kehrten wir zu wirtschaftsformen aus der
römerzeit zurück
die basieren auf ganz anderen werten ein
system zu finden das jahrhundertelang
nachhaltig sein wird erfordert einen
völlig anderen denkansatz
das muss man erst mal sacken lassen also
zurück zu den römern aber vorher müssen
wir den klimawandel stoppen das ist das
wichtigste wir müssen tun was wir können
und die politiker auf rechnen als
individuen können wir den leuten helfen
zu verstehen wie dringlich dieses
problem ist und wir können den
politikern helfen zu verstehen dass sie
im interesse der menschheit handeln
müssen und nicht im interesse der
großkonzerne wie das viele leute das
sagen sich ja die heutige demokratie ist
eine scheindemokratie und das ist eine
schöne wie sagen sie plutokratie das
geld regiert die welt und es ist nicht
mehr von den bürgern gesteuert sondern
von den unternehmen genau
wir haben unsere macht und unseren
einfluss den konzernen überlassen und
das ist ein großer teil des problems
ich denke mir immer es bräuchte ich
einfach mehr emotionale betroffenheit
weil die haut zum teil oder jetzt noch
fehlt weil wir die diese katastrophe
noch nicht am eigenen leib spüren
bräuchte es nicht erzählungen vielmehr
auch die uns irgendwie das spürbar
machen wir das leben in 50 jahren
aussehen wird damit sich die leute das
endlich mal vorstellen können eine große
schwierigkeit ist wie wir die botschaft
an die leute bringen al gore braucht es
einen film vor ein paar jahren heraus
und später produzierte er weitere filme
wir hatten den bericht die grenzen des
wachstums oder 1962 das sachbuch stumme
frühling die biologin rachel kassen mehr
als 50 jahre lang haben wir alles
versucht um den leuten zu verstehen zu
geben wie gross und dringlich das
problem
wir haben versagt die umweltbewegung hat
versagt wir haben nichts erreicht keine
veränderung
nun habe ich dieses buch geschrieben
grund für unser früheres scheitern war
wohl schlechtes timing
es braucht den moment in dem die
menschen bereit sind hinzusehen wenn die
leute mitbekommen dass 92 menschen in
griechenland verbrennen dass ein
hurrikan new york verwüstet oder die
bäume im süden portugals sterben dann
wachen sie auf das timing ist besser
aber die leute sind noch nicht
aufmerksam genug
vielen herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch ich danke ihnen
ja und wir sehen uns bereits am
kommenden samstagabend wieder wenn sie
möchten und zwar um 21 15 auf sf2 zur
sternstunde der nacht diesmal mit
menschen die auffallen und zwar weil sie
ganz anders aussehen als die meisten von
uns ob gewollt oder nicht
und jetzt gleich gibt sternstunde kunst
einen einblick in das künstlerische
schaffen der schweizer malerin barbara
werder die unter freiem himmel
wilde berglandschaften auf die leinwand
zaubert und das bei jedem wetter und zu
jeder jahreszeit ziehen sie sich aus dem
rahmen und einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]